for all the meetings that happened for
this david blaine stunt to happen
right there's all the logistics you have
to work through yeah there was a meeting
where someone goes maybe even david
blaine himself goes okay now
if i have to [ __ ]
worth worth planning i mean
epa there were there were phone calls in
emails there's probably a slack channel
devoted
just to yeah taking care of
what happens if he has to pee or poop i
mean blaine blaine has probably had to
have that conversation a lot of times
right like every single one of his
stunts involves
conversations you would have to have
about peeing and pooping with strangers
like it must be
something he's very comfortable having
conversations with people about
i did science journalism for a while i
think i probably told you guys about it
before and it was my favorite because um
a lot of it was
taking uh something comp complicated on
the science website and then spending
whatever
like translating it and because she's
like
nobody's saying you're fine
i could fix that in the edit nobody
would know oh now we just said no no
her internet her internet shout out as
we were talking about david blaine
digging a poop
what i love is it's gonna be it's gonna
be like contact where
she's gonna have 18 hours worth of uh
but
the truth is it recorded 18 hours
oh my back yeah you're like i can't tell
um and one that was not that was not an
intentional gaslighting
no we're not creating the illusion did
you pre-plan this just ignore
cartman so one of the the most fun
stories i
had to write uh was about how
nasa was actually legitimately trying to
figure out a way
to safely let their astronauts poop
inside of spacesuits for long-haul
flights
without like doing damage to their skin
um they were like
could we create like a vacuum do they
permanently have hoses in their butts
they couldn't figure it out so they had
to uh launch a competition for it so it
ended up being like global prize money
to figure out how to let help us poop
[ __ ] in the spacesuits yeah
those things those competitions are
always amazing though like
the the the ingenuity that people come
up with to me that's a way better way to
do r d anyway because
it's like okay somebody somebody come up
with the
you know really clever solution and then
we'll kind of iterate on it there's a
lot of
stories like that of people coming up
with really slick solutions of
uh very unconventional problems
david blaine won that competition david
blaine was the guy who created the space
suit
[ __ ] that was uh that was what i'm
trying to understand
is like what is this like how high up is
he now
is it for troy troy he's trying to work
out david like go for a troy
yeah it's like stand this man three
miles like you're
like the red bull guy went higher right
yeah it's not even [ __ ] cool david
blaine your [ __ ]
three miles what are you doing i say we
get some balloons we go up there we meet
him we tell him how awful we think his
idea is
excuse me hi mike mike mike biffle here
play watch listen just a couple of
questions for you
for some reason i have an old
anachronistic mic
excuse me mr blaine this is fight
i want to point out i'm about six inches
higher than you i'm winning right now
is he wearing a mask that would be that
that would be one of the fundamental
separations right like i think he's
going off the region
thingy like uh yeah he's too
narcissistic to wear a
tarot mask that's a mustache just a
really really big mustache
he grew his mustache out so extensively
that he can like shape it to be a mask
over his mouth
it actually holds air that's how big it
is now it can hold oxygen
nice i mean i figured that it was a spin
off of
up and it this article references it i
guess it is
but i wonder is it is like there's no
way pixar involved in this nonsense
no i i can't imagine david blaine
sitting at home watching
up and going
that could be me that's it do i have any
balloons
that's immediately true his first move
is to immediately then go poison his
wife
i was gonna say he's sitting next to his
wife and he's like i have an idea
and then he's like i'll be right back
i'll be right back
i don't think david blaine is married i
just don't
i don't see that guy having like i could
be wrong
i think it'd be hilarious if he turns
out to have this like really domestic
like snap snapshot of life at home with
david blaine and it's like oh
sweetie did you do your homework you
just i know long division is
always a trouble spot and it's like
turns out he's just this
i can do that you don't believe me
watch yeah that sounds right just before
he went in the balloon
like just just before this like yes
2014 look how bored he looks he's like
this is a stupid idea
he's like i did not think through the
timing of this he's like
for a while i should have had to be a
poop conversation that's what he's
thinking right now he's thinking i
should have had that meeting
i hope he's binging past episodes of
play watch listen while he's hanging no
i
i think he's like
no it's like this he was like and now i
finally watched the wire
[Laughter]
all right last last season of game of
thrones here we go
nobody can tell me reasons for that it's
crazy if he falls we have to re-record
all of this by the way
like obviously oh
it started off great it started off
great hey why do you guys go from
episode 27 to 29 we don't
you know yes that was technical hassle
yeah
the david blaine incident don't worry
about it just feverish
alana going we're taking the week off
everybody
gave them a break bye hi everyone
everyone another episode of play watch
listen i'm doing the intro
six minutes in rather than an hour in
like last week uh i'm alana pierce i've
been in games media for almost a decade
i'm joined by austin wintery he's a
video game composer
famously known for journey everything
else is fine
it's just that one easily dismissed
which i really specifically wanted to
bring up because
uh last week we asked the question of
video games about death and
austin did not mention journey himself
yeah
yeah it's funny how i didn't even think
about that i didn't mean to well
until yeah i was perusing the comments
on youtube
and there were multiple people going um
journey yeah and what
what i really loved was that there were
people that brought up journey
in a way that made it seem like they
actually weren't aware i worked on it uh
it was like oh you should check out
journey uh and i was like
thinking about it i i'm pretty yeah
pretty sure
i could like some of these i can feel
the sarcasm transparently enough but
some of these seem
kind of innocently like oh i know
exactly the one to suggest
funny i think my favorite suggestion was
um
red dead redemption 2 you know you're
going to die
and and that game did a really good job
for me of like i was constantly worried
about
when arthur was going to die i was
scared
so it was just like this constant thing
of like any time anything emotional was
happening being like oh is this it
oh i'm gonna lose him oh no hold on hold
on when do you know that you're going to
die
as soon as you're diagnosed with
tuberculosis uh
i think it's like saying the entire game
i was like hold on no
i mean you wouldn't even know when it
actually happens because it's like it's
that
he beats up someone with tb and then
it like transfers into his mouth i guess
um so you have i told you
eventually but my thing with that and
it's it's
i was i i carved out time in my life i
was like i told pamela's like you need
to understand when this game comes out
i'm not doing anything like i've been
waiting years for this game to come out
and i'm gonna be the david blaine of
this relationship exactly
[Laughter]
he's doing well with yeah i'm still
watching it yeah i'm still watching
dudes far more fascinating than this
this conversation this little anecdote
but
i finally was like i have time to pick
this game back up because i was so deep
into it
and there was a corruption with my save
game and it put me back on the island i
went
no like i grinded to get off that island
i killed the woman and everything and it
was like
i also had a safe game issue and went
nope i went i'm never going to finish
this game because i don't
i love i'm always the same way i i it's
a strange thing if
after you've invested a certain amount
of time if something sidelines that or
if it
if yeah like your you know save gets
lost or or whatever you got to reinstall
i've had that experience where i'm like
all right that's it it's done it's yeah
like i i
i the the uphill climb is so
unappealing especially you're giving me
right now it's just
yeah dude that's all my protest is on
our next thing this
week this week i accidentally like
corrupted all of our save
system so every play test i had to
restart our next project from the start
yeah i love that for that that's a
terrifying thing featured
you know you know the the funny thing
though like
as a slight kind of corollary to that is
when i'm writing a piece of music every
now and again fortunately i've gotten
really obsessive
with my my various modes of backup that
i don't know that this is really
possible anymore but
especially 10 years ago every now and
again it would happen
working on something for a few hours a
save file gets corrupted back before
the software had a built-in auto save
feature where it's constantly creating
new you know files there were a lot of
ways that this could
could go sideways and sure enough every
now and again you know hours or a day of
work would get lost
and what i always found is that when i
went you know
there's the grieving period where you're
like you're looking here
actually it starts with the denial it
starts with the denial where i spend
you know thank you for all gathering
today does anyone want to say anything
before basically yes it's more like it's
more like i should rethink my career
this is [ __ ]
you know like just absolute instant
depression of just like
[ __ ] and then and then what invariably
happens is i have to start from scratch
and the new version is just there's no
way it's not better than the previous
one
you're applying the lessons learned
right yeah oh it's the same with games
though is that
is that you know what i mean like well
that's the thing i i
i i i yeah i i well i think it i don't
know it depends on the kind of game
of course um but if it was if it was
like an rpg
where you know i've i've done a lot of
grinding or i've done a lot of exploring
and then now i'm kind of setting the
clock back but with the benefit of all
that i learned
i might actually more efficiently make
my way through it which is
kind of the the hold up of the analogy
yeah but like with red dead that's not
possible it's like
you can't right you have to do that
whole big battle again
you have to do i was like i don't want
to do and again that game is beautiful
roger clark's like did you finish the
game yet troy have you
have you have you gone through it yet
i'm like i
i need you to know we're always going to
be friends i'm never going to finish
that game
as much as i love it i'm never gonna
finish that game
our friend jack atridge the america
creative director he
finished the game i remember when it
first came out and then you know maybe a
month later or something he posted on i
think instagram you know i just finished
and i said what was your play time and
he goes
like 170 hours or something insane and i
said i said it was that
a positive experience he goes i kind of
feel like i have stockholm syndrome
because i love the game i love the game
as a sort of
because yeah
i think it was jack i went out for
dinner with like when he was in that
period and it really was
like like the game had hurt him like he
he genuinely like there was like a
100-yard stare
wait but you didn't play you didn't
start it there though you didn't like a
lot of you need to leave you've been
here
um that would be a good use of cinemas
now i'm realizing they could rent them
out one person at a time
uh it was very cool i rented it out for
resident evil 2 remake and had like a
bunch of friends
come through with snacks and drinks and
whatever and we played through the whole
game which was awesome but i i basically
did you also have
like david blaine did you also have to
have meals okay so what do i need to do
in the event how's my slice
popcorn bucket alana here's this popcorn
i was trying to figure out a way
to get the david blaine feed to be like
permanently
in the middle of the video um but then i
can you know figure out how to turn the
audio on off for it so
like i could try it again but uh let me
reintroduce everyone else also
also joined by troy baker video game
actor and mike
yeah he's more important by the way
just so you understand my perspective
like this is what this whole thing is
all about that's what we're here for
right that is the
mic is going to be different but mike is
down here by the way i have to add
you were so missed like alana you
weren't in like
our our circle at that point but i wish
you would have been there too
you would have had fun that night that
we had in london
um where uh ben was there
thank him that dinner jack attributes um
we just had this there's this great
restaurant little pub in london uh
called punchbowl and we rented the upper
room like
the disciples of christ hey i fitted in
there someone say star wars
um it was a great night it's
horrible yeah we are being quite boring
though by just talking about our friends
uh without like
[Music]
hey guys um there's a weird jump in time
in the podcast it was
the most boring part of the episode
troy talked about a dinner party a
little bit of crackle
uh dude i know did i tell you what the
solution was
well i mean it's still there gear
replacement
uh no i from elgato they said that the
solution is
it goes oh if you're on a pc then you
need to do this update i was like cool
what's the solution if you're on a mac
he was like oh the solution is different
for a mac i was like is it to get a pc
pretty much excellent
um spoken like a true gamer
today i wanted to talk a little bit
about um backwards compatibility
specifically uh it's been making the
news because
ubisoft australia posted in a q a
that they then had to update basically
saying
uh let me find the exact quote but it's
ultimately that the the ps5 will not be
terribly backwards compatible
sorry david blade is falling through the
air is that intentional i know i just
saw that
mike and i had the same reaction i was
like pull that over real quick
that's part of the plan did he get to
the height where he wanted to
okay it said he would it said he'd go to
three miles and then
parachute to the ground i want to know
what flat earthers are doing right now i
really want to know what flat earthers
are doing right now
david blaine's in on there he's part of
the conspiracy wouldn't that be great if
he is himself a flat earther
like i can prove it i saw the ice wall
i'm so sorry
for derailing this episode i'm so sorry
i've ruined that
it's absolutely fine it's going to suck
for audio listeners but for this
here's the david blaine content here
here's the question
is is landlocked david blaine backwards
compatible with formerly
balloon that's what i'm saying but david
blaine that's interesting because from a
consumer perspective you'd expect that
to be the case but there's actually a
lot of very interesting complexities to
uh to the differences between david
blaine's very good
that's well and that's that's the
takeaway for mike
very good now it's boring that's boring
now we know he's going to live
you know it's fine what is what is the
cost to do backwards compatibility for
an
existing system right no that's because
between zero and a million dollars
yeah yeah i think somewhere it varies um
so that's way more dismissive than
intended choice sorry i was going for a
joke but actually no no no no
it's not dismissive at all i i i'm
coming in from
troy i'm coming at this from a from a
position of ignorance but
i always like i i love the fact that um
that uh infinity ward did finally did a
remaster of modern warfare
uh modern warfare 2 but they only did
the
um campaign which i understand but i was
like
do the spec op missions like i
understand why you don't want to support
that server-wise and do the multiplayer
because you're really pushing
zone and you don't want to split your
audience i get that but i didn't
understand
why it was why it was so expensive to do
one part but not the other like it feels
like if you're just going to do one
do the other but that's what i was like
what is the co-op expects the co-op
aspect
yeah well
i get i guess but you could also i guess
if you're gonna do
if you're gonna do it might as well do
it all the way that was my favorite part
the mission was great but
that was my favorite part of that game
was
uh the spec op missions but that's why i
didn't know it's like it's not like
we're deving for a new platform but we
already have that code
we're just applying our assets to that
so i don't know what that cost is
but apparently it's tremendous well it
varies i imagine in that case probably
the call of duty one was probably
millions like because it was also
a bunch of new assets as well it wasn't
just uh like an
up so that's the other thing is there's
like five different kinds of ways you
can update a game
right in terms of like it can be just a
straight up port
with no changes it can be a port in an
upgrade it can be a complete rebuild
um and often like those look very
similar to the end user like the player
doesn't necessarily know which one that
is so for example
with our games thomas was alone the
playstation version of that game was
completely rebuilt from scratch because
at the time we
released that you couldn't port unity
onto playstation there was no unity for
playstation
so we had literally a dev team of i
think like eight
people basically rebuilt thomas was
alone from scratch in
a few months because it was a very
simply made game it was about rectangles
right it was made by an idiot it's fine
but literally they built it as a new
game essentially
so but no no one in the audience knows
or cares about that right because it's
it
ends up being basically the same thing
from their perspective but you also have
like porting which is you know
essentially just running in like an
emulator or something like or
is similar to the way you do it with an
emulator so it can massively vary
but that's not quite the same which came
out which
might as well have been like a full new
aaa production
this is the real trick of david blaine
by the way oh did something go wrong
there oh he's back you froze see first
for a second
yeah i'm like it's all right it was like
it's david blaine's fault it's because
he's
messing with the satellites he's just
cutting he's getting in the way of them
he's getting in the way of them he's
putting balloons in the way of them he
saw mike's signal coming and he reached
out
i guess the main question is is what is
the benefit or how
um if if like i is the consumer i want
every game to be backwards compatible
like because i still have my ps3 i still
have my you know i'm gonna keep my ps4
and i'll have a ps5 but what is the
benefit to the dev
for backwards compatibility well troy if
you already if you have those consoles
what's the benefit to you
uh convenience so that i wouldn't have
to like i keep my ps3 because there's
some games that are not backwards
compatible
um i guess i keep so anyway but i mean i
also love backwards compatibility for
the convenience but i'm
trying to figure out how important this
actually is to
the general public because it doesn't
seem like much of a selling point for
xbox even though
they focus very hard on backwards
compatible it's not making people stay
on that
hardware and it's not making them sell
any better it's like how important
actually
is it from a business perspective i
yeah i think i think it's one of those
ones that definitely i've got in trouble
on this podcast before saying this like
there are certain things that players
want but the numbers imply that they
don't actually make use of them like
they want to know that they could
you want to know i was going to go and
play those games but you're actually
realistically just going to mostly play
music yeah
i remember when you mentioned that in
the context of replayability and i
remember that feeling
actually quite not revelatory but
well actually in the in the senses the
opposite of revelatory was like that
feels very right i
i can't ever remember buying a game on
the basis of the opposite
of revelatory i'm getting a t-shirt by
the way that's my teacher
that's a that's the that's the
lesser-known uh origin of bethelian
yeah it's the opposite of revelatory um
that's an interesting one because i feel
the same way like replayability i
understand the importance again
especially for people who don't have
high income who can only play a certain
amount of games in a year but
as much as i like the idea of
replayability i mean kingdoms of ammo or
the re-reckoning is coming out soon and
i'm like
hell yeah i love that game and then i
was like but what
i but what about all these other games
that i already haven't played
should i really be playing the
re-reckoning of kingdoms of amalon right
now
because even that is a game that like
i'm like oh but it's updated but i'm
like [ __ ] but there's so much other
stuff that i should be playing
i mean you do claim to be a grant
kirkhope fan so i guess this is going to
be the true test i am a fan of
grandchild cup good dude good dude
it's banjo-kazooie man so there's
actually greatest soundtrack of all time
he's he's phenomenal
he's my he's my second favorite after
characters
um with yeah that's i mean you can't
compete with with the whole like miami
soundtrack
no you can't no the but but this is
where it gets no it's specifically
you austin yeah yeah you
grant grant kirk yeah grant has no
problem competing with hotline man
so yeah so there's we've already run
into the immediate problem of where
there's a bunch of different things
we're talking about here so there's
backwards compatibility
which generally refers to console side
so that's a console that can effectively
emulate a previous version of the
console
so your xbox one can pretend to be an
xbox 360
and theoretically run most xbox 360
games that's a backwards
doesn't that add a lot of
sorry i wasn't trying to cut you off
yeah go ahead i was gonna ask doesn't it
doesn't i seem to recall when the ps4
was coming out
that that was a big discussion because
it was adding a lot to the price point
of the console itself like
well that was because yeah that was
because their their solution was to put
a literal ps
was it the ps4 or the ps3 where they
literally actually think it was they put
the old console
they put ps2 inside the launch day ps3
just
because it's not that simple that's the
big thing is like i i uh
interviewed i think it was with ryan
mccaffrey while i was at ign the
backwoods compatibility team at
microsoft
that is a full dedicated team that's not
just a
yeah we just run an emulator it's it's a
full team whose entire jobs is to
make backwards compatibility function um
they're building an emulator they're
building the world's best emulator which
is the other aspect of this which is i
think a lot of the time players have
downloaded like a snare emulator and be
able to play mario and that's cool
but there's two aspects there sorry i'm
sorry yo
the super famicom i apologize snares no
no no no no
i think it's a european thing i think
europeans say it's more the more classy
kind of reforms yes i'm also european
and i say
yes
yeah but do you you don't you don't walk
around calling it a nest oh i've got a
nest
i have yeah you do before actually yeah
i'm with troy on this one it'd be really
funny anyway disconnected from the call
yeah just reappears as reappears as
david blaine
uh it's the uh the but i love it
is that i've been david blaine the
entire time
what's funny is that it did actually
rearrange where you are in the window
now so
now your pointing may be accurate mike
he's in a helicopter now i think blaine
is playing is now mocking
david blaine is in the helicopter this
is the most boring report i've ever done
in my time in a helicopter
um where are we i don't what is this
episode i don't know i was talking
about that so i'm gonna come back
yes so emulation um so yeah people
downloaded this
snes emulator and they've and it's
worked and they've been like why can't
we just have this
the problems are one obviously games got
more complicated two what's more
important
is the emulator you downloaded was not a
commercial product that had to hit
the criteria the commercial product does
have to so you the emulator you
downloaded
may break with like one percent of games
it may
accidentally damage something it might
not work it might be testing it might
have a
rare bug that when you sell it to a
million people that bug comes up
10 times and that's your youtube video
of the the thing going wrong
so there's a massive expectations
applied to the folks doing the xbox
backwards compatibility
they're not making they're making an
emulator but it has to be a full proof
emulator has to be a really
professionally produced piece of
software and that
obviously takes time and money and team
um
well yeah that's cool but there's always
going to be those gaps
it's not as simple as we made the
emulator now all the xbox games run
uh it's that they have to basically
re-emulate or tinker with it literally
every single game oh it's not the same
well that's cause every game is a hack
every game is a hack every game is like
just teetering on the edge of what you
can get away with like if you look at
something yeah
all games are like mad max vehicles uh
they really like
they billow smoke and and like duct tape
is holding together core engine parts
and actively like actively breaking the
engine to do things right like there's
there's
there's almost every console generation
like in that last year the reason you're
getting all those
those games that just look way beyond
what you could imagine at the at the
start of generation
is those developers have gotten good at
cheating they've gotten good at like
breaking
the game there are so many tricks that
you can use to basically like
use hardware weirdly like stupid like um
running your physics through the sound
engine stuff like that like the
everything you can do to kind of squeeze
things out i'm listening
but you can do like there's that's a bad
example because actually we're doing the
other way around anyway
um but you like just squeezing all the
performance you can out which yes means
that
any emulator is going to run into
problems at the the extremes of that
sorry i'm just talking a lot i apologize
no i i you know it's interesting
i want to know best i think the
distinction between porting and
backwards compel
compatibility is interesting because one
of those seems to pose no danger to
the particular work that i do like back
like running a ps3 game on a ps4
for example theoretically you're you're
taking
something from a more constrained
environment to a less constrained
environment that seems like
presuming the ps4 uh
can handle what it takes to to run
a ps3 game the the the specs of the
hardware itself
would theoretically be you know it would
be all the easier for this thing to run
because the thing that i
see all the time is um when games
shift platforms and
all the work that we put in to try and
make especially super interactive scores
like they just may not be as easily
handled um
on a on a new piece of hardware and and
case in point
um i i wasn't involved at all so i don't
really know the story here but as soon
as journey
hit pc i started getting a lot of tweets
from people saying the music
doesn't work right compared to the
playstation version like it's just not a
clean
port and i i haven't actually played
through it but it wouldn't surprise me
because our system was
crazy complicated and it wouldn't take
much to break it i think
it had never even occurred to me that
music would be included in something
that is difficult to
make backwards or forwards compatible
because it's so connected to all the
systems of the game that if something's
going on wrong with them
the music will basically get confused
and not know what to do that's why we're
training
a score that's an mp3 that plays
i can see a version of this where would
be a lot easier
someone has to kind of run the numbers
and say okay
um if we're gonna do a remaster of this
game
what is the cost of making that game
backwards compatible versus doing a
remaster
it's kind of like the whole fight club
thing where edward norton says
if we we do the data analytics and if
the cost of a recall is more expensive
than paying out the interest claim we
don't do one
so i was like maybe that's that's what
it is it's like i understand that you
really want a remake of
kingdom hearts too or whatever i was
going to say yes
i'm ready but what do you think replay
value is very relevant on that one
perfect example would you say there's
more value to doing
a this is all speculative i understand
but is it more valuable to do a
remastered version
versus backwards compatibility and
amortize that over
how much it would cost to make not just
mass effect backwards compatible but
all of those games compatible backwards
compatible versus just doing a remaster
is it cheaper to just do a remaster of
the ones you know will sell
versus just doing a cart launch like you
said backwards compatibility for all
your entire categories well you'd still
you'd still need to do it per game like
even if they're in the same engine you
would there is still like
each backwards compatibility would also
be a discrete kind of job that you have
to do you have to
get that done but it would be cheap xbox
says
the master chief collection collection's
a perfect example is that okay the
master collection has had to release
games staggered especially now that
they're on pc
uh they're doing them chronologically in
order of it's chronological the right
word
so reaches first is what i'm trying to
say here um
but it takes it can take that six plus
months
to release a new one uh but if they
say if they go we are backwards
compatible does that
not explicitly say or at least
implicitly
mean that all of your games all your ps3
games all of your xbox one games are
going to run
on this new machine if you say we are
backwards compatible or is it only
saying can't make that promise
like even now there's games that you
can't play on the xbox one from the xbox
360. right there's
there's games i think it's games of mine
that you can't play because basically
they
sell well enough that anyone's bothered
to kind of worry about bringing them
forward i think there's
yeah dead to rights retribution which
was an xbox 360 game i worked on which
i don't think you can play that
backwards unbabel on xbox one because
they just
that team has other things to be doing
so no you never be able to make a 100
backwards compatible system
unless you do the playstation 3 method
of literally taking the bits of a piece
putting one in there
inside the box the um the other things
were do you think that that gamble paid
off for them
sorry but just because that that is what
drove the cost difference i guess
do you think that that was a calculably
profitable move or
if it had been they'd still be selling
them a month or two yeah yeah
they killed that they stopped selling
those and the 360 sold
better at the start of the year so i
think that like at that the ps3 did end
up selling more than the xbox 360 by the
end but i think in the beginning they
were trying to recover from that
this thing is way too expensive like
marketing it was an engineer solution do
you remember
very brute force solution to the problem
you know it's very much kind of
we're screwed we'll just sell you a ps3
with a ps2 inside that yeah
the young but the other thing here is
just really important and it's worth
noting with remasters and it's
interesting you brought master chief
collection
the often the primary purpose of a
remaster because it is a massive
investment is not the expectation that
you'll sell and make profit on the game
they're usually marketing it's usually
something you put the effort into
to get the audience reengaged with an ip
you've not released anything in
which is why every remaster comes out
about a year before the new iteration in
the series
because it's about building it's about
reminding your audience
who lost interest yeah the audience
who've not played the halo game in next
number of years
hey here's all the halo you could
possibly want just kind of get you back
into it
and also to introduce it to a whole new
audience those are media beats that you
can get you know
you can pay streamers to to talk about
halo you can get all of this noise going
and then when the new halo comes out you
can you can kind of ride that wave
that's why those generally happen with
first part
with mass effect it's it seems so
obvious they just
aren't guaranteed to make the millions
everyone's like you're gonna make so
much money from mass effect exactly
i think that's so funny that's so weird
that would be the announcement of the
new mass effect game will be the box
once that box set of the mass effect
trilogy comes out then congratulations
you're getting a mass effect announced
at the next e3
like that's like clockwork every single
time the only outsider on that is
sometimes first
party so something like last of us is a
really interesting case in point where
that first game have you heard of last
of us that's one that i think we've
talked about on the show before
um the last of us
it's 2d platform here it was uh it was
from the uh the banjo-kazooie
um but it came out it came out right at
the end of the console generation right
so they did the remaster onto ps4
because it was basically bluntly high
quality content they could get
relatively cheap as a as a game for the
ps4 at launch where they needed as much
content as they could get
so sometimes first part you'll do it for
that reason obviously that remaster
wasn't trying to sell you one last of us
two because last of us two was gonna
was six years away seven years away by
the time that game that that version
yeah so it's it's it's usually done with
an ulterior motive like there's usually
a reason to do a remaster beyond
or checking in on whether crash
bandicoot's popular you know
before you bring out the crash bandicoot
uh the new black crash bandicoot
you do the market research by
re-releasing the crash bandicoot
remaster
i think it was a year before or a couple
years before you see if the audience is
there you see which audience are
interested in it
what are the what are the streamers who
are into crash bandicoot the easiest way
to find that out is to
release a remaster see where that goes
and go okay these are the ten big
influences that we need to
make sure are involved in the audience
so it's it's a market research thing as
well it's a there's a lot of it's not
just about how much
you can sell that's really really smart
because you're like okay
if it costs us for for easy math if it
costs us a million dollars to do
a remaster of this and we find out
that people don't want this we just
saved ourselves potentially
25 30 50 million dollars or more
of doing that that's that's really small
games you've never heard of coming out
that got cancelled because of a remaster
doing badly there will be i don't know
of any but there will be
development teams who are working on the
new iteration of franchising the
remaster came out and no one cared
and that was quite turning off right now
it happens
which is crazy this is why it looks like
a remake but it is a remaster
yeah that's crazy that's it that's why
like i i ask about
because my perspective on backwards
compatibility just because i
i the the limit of my knowledge extends
only so far
right so i don't under i understand a
little bit about what happens behind the
scenes
but like when someone goes when they
come out at e3 and they go
and we will be backwards compatible in
the fanfare falls and the confetti and
everything
my my dumb brain automatically assumes
i can play every game i currently have a
disc for
on that new machine that's what that's
what i assume
sometimes you don't even have licenses
so sometimes you
on to i think the xbox team said this
that you they aren't allowed to make
every original
xbox game forwards compatible
uh because they don't have the license
to do that for some of them so it's but
do you
think that that's kind of like that's in
the fine print you know what i mean it's
it's
the public facing of that is more
people like me going i can play that's
why i
they put that feature on there is
because people go again
i may never use it but i want to know
that it has
like every car that has onstar most
people never use it
if that's still even a thing but that's
the thing
focused on the feature that you have
there's all sorts of [ __ ] that my car
can do
that i never elon musk is is a big
component of this when it comes to
um everything that tesla goes most most
owners of a tesla
only use like 30 of the features of what
the car can do
but they tell you all the features so
that you buy it do you think that's a
marketing ploy for for backwards
compatibility where it's like people
will think
that their existing catalog has more
value than it really does
i think it's actually well what's
interesting is it's becoming more true
we're heading towards i think and i
don't know how far it is the licensing
thing that alana mentions is a really
big issue and that's that's come up a
few times with a few major games like um
marvel licensed stuff for example like i
remember when there was a deadpool game
with
it was now the north right playing
deadpool in like yeah this is exposed
and you can you can't buy that game
anymore it comes up all the time with
licensed stuff
it's an activision one i think high
moves activation i think activision lost
the marvel license so
yeah um yeah so
that's a really good point like i
remember when we were doing telltale
batman
we had to ship that game because they
held the license
for this narrow window period and if we
didn't ship the game they lost it and i
was like
what does that mean it's like we can't
do the game we we get like a two-year
window
and and we where we have a hot potato
and i was i was fascinated by that so
that's why it again there's some making
games is hard i'm i'm learning yeah
it is um i do the go ahead mike
i'm sorry i'm interrupting you i
apologize the um
[Laughter]
the expectation you have that your
content like that
essentially your back catalog will
retain its value and you can keep
playing these games
that does from a technical point of view
that is becoming easier every day
because
essentially and this is what you see
with the xbox approach which is
basically we're gonna
we're gonna iterate hardware like a
mobile phone or like uh like a like an
ipad like we're gonna
we're gonna keep releasing xboxes and
you get the one the year you want a new
xbox and
and that's gonna kind of exist in the
ecosystem for
three or four years before it becomes
obsolete so you're you're not like
selling a console every eight years
you're selling a console every year and
then
the audience just kind of come in and
out as they want with that being the
case
there is a requirement for us a
consistency of compatibility
that lasts a bit longer that doesn't
mean it does it's last forever which
we've seen already with like
ios games that you can't play anymore
stuff like that so there is there is
still a shelf life but that's coming in
where it becomes um sorry troy you want
to say something right i apologize
no i was just i'm just pouring one out
for my zuma
i there's an ipad that i keep that i
will never update because
yeah that's what they're going for but
where it gets really interesting is that
if we end up with a game pass style
system that gets even
trickier in the same way as netflix like
because your your
your content no longer exists on your
shelf it's it's a library that is on a
right exterior server so gears
only exists until it doesn't now
obviously it will
it will exist forever it's gears but
there's a lot of like with netflix there
are things that will fall off there are
things
how many times have you been watching
like i've happened to be so many times
i've been like halfway through a show on
netflix
stop watching it for a month come back
and it's gone from netflix because of
different deals
or in different regions too
like there's some shows that i can watch
oh my god
before ducktales was on something i was
like in the sales like oh my god they
have ducktales they had robotech or
there was something weird on netflix
and i was like i can't believe it i came
back home they're like no i went
no mikey you saying that
with systems like game pass which does
feel like the inevitable direction that
we're headed in
really sure backwards compatibility
will get harder or is it more that
you're saying that it's just that
we will have no ownership of those
things because they get taken off the
server and we lose them entirely
i'm saying that like in theory from a
consumer but
as with all these things there'll be
loads of work behind the scenes by
developers of course with the consumer
point of view
i in theory something like game pass
means that backwards compatibility won't
need to exist because
it won't from a consumer point of view
it won't be a a generational console
world anymore it'll be
i own an xbox oh which one which model
do you have i've got the 2020 in the
xbox
or i've got the 2019 xbox and then
there will be exactly that's what i'm
saying but but like the iphone there
will inevitably be
technological leaps where you will not
work you will no longer
be able to play much older games and
that's where it gets interesting we'll
we're going to slide back into that
needs for need for backwards
compatibility at that point but what's
interesting with
modern consoles is they are basically
built on pc architecture which means
that
it's everything's in right now sure
but that's that's the same thing that
you're saying though it's like
i own like i i've got um
something stupid like 500 movies on my
itunes because i just i
i'm a i'm a buyer i like to build my
collection
but that's different than having like a
bookshelf
right over there things still disappear
from it right
yes uh i've had i've i actually got into
an argument with someone from apple
because i think it was what we do in the
shadows
the you know the comedy movie i i owned
it on itunes it disappeared from my
itunes
and i called them and they were like
yeah the the distributor
removed that version of the film and put
up a new version like cool i just
can i just have the new version of that
film there same film can i can you
fix that just move the thing over no i'm
afraid you have to repurchase it you
don't technically
yeah thank you sir um so that that
because i like you troy i like to which
the only response was do you know who i
am
perhaps you didn't hear my name like
netflix
it was actually outside apple floating
um sir please come down um but that's
the same thing with games and i know a
lot of this is a big
button with you it's like not actually
physically
or in any way owning
that game that there's gonna have to be
a tremendous
leap in in culture and mindset
of buying that game which means that
naturally as game pass develops
there will not be that like
the notion of paying 12 15 20
for an album is
people like what are you crazy if it's
if it's not on vinyl that's a complete
non-starter
right if it's not some collector's thing
but
why would i piece you paid 60 do you
remember
most of you guys probably don't remember
this but but before like in the
90s even to buy a
like a videotape of a movie
would cost like 350 dollars
what yes like a disney like a disney
animated movie i remember those were the
ones that were really
anything it was like and i worked in a
video store it was like the replacement
cost of so
every video that owned in a video store
that wasn't a blockbuster whatever
if you looked at that cost it was like
that movie cost 250 dollars i was like
what are you talking about it costs 4.99
to rent it's like right that's how we
make our money back
but to own that movie like you want to
own a copy of this that's like owning a
print of that movie and so it used to
cost 250 bucks
and the same way that there was a whole
generation of phones that were
if you wanted to go i'm sure you rewind
that [ __ ] that's from pecan
in the same way that if you wanted to go
buy a phone a a
cell phone cost eight hundred dollars
it was like and then the i remember the
day that
this feels like a tangent but i'm going
somewhere with this i remember the day
that it happened
i was standing out i worked at a cell
phone shop it's honestly disappointing
to know this is going somewhere i prefer
back in my life i remember where i was
in this i worked at a cell phone store
and my manager was like
holy [ __ ] and he showed us in the
newspaper
there was an advert that someone had
taken out going the motorola star tech
was the phone it was
this clamshell phone it was it was a
small phone
and everybody wanted it and some store
was saying we're giving it away for a
dollar
and it was because they were gonna make
the money off the cell phone contracts
that they could amortize that loss or
that cost
over the course of two or three you get
you had to sign up for two years
and they were like we're willing to do
this exactly and so what it did was it
dropped the value of phones because now
phones were a dollar and it wasn't until
2006
or 2007 when the iphone came back and
apple went
it's 500 people like you're out of your
mind i've been paying 30 bucks 20 bucks
a dollar for a phone
and they're like we're we're selling
hardware we're not selling contract
service now
we partnered with a t or we partnered
with sprint and you can get a reduction
in the cost if you sign up for new
service with them but if you want to
buy this phone and finally over the last
14 years people have gone
oh phones now cost 500 bucks so
we're going to hit that that peak where
a game to buy a game
we're going to look and go you used to
pay 60 bucks for a game
it's it's 9.99 it's 15 bucks a month
that's scary they're uh then that's why
every triple-a and
produce gaming yeah no go ahead that's
all i have to say
that's why every triple a that's why
every triple
that's why every aaa game company is
building games of service that's why
every game now is
we're going to keep you playing for
months this is a lifestyle game
because they're basically preempting
where they believe and probably are
right the market's going to go which is
that you're not going to pay for that
but is that developing out of fear or is
that developing out of proactive
response
i think it's proactive i think they i
think the scale of
aaa requires it i think on the indie
side i don't think i require i think i
can i can make a smaller game
and i know that there's going to be a
niche who want to play my kind of game
and they'll see it are you the final of
of games
are you the 100 yeah if i was if i was
actively making games that cost as much
as
a major aaa game cost to make i think
i'd probably be looking in the live
service thing
it wouldn't suit my tastes and what i
like to make and how i like my games to
feel but like
i'd probably be leaning in that
direction because i do i think they're
probably right i think
the luxury aaa game for 60 dollars
outside of the kind of the system seller
essentially the kind of the first party
uh game i think is is not gonna last for
much longer
i think but i do think that hipsters
like me can do essentially the
equivalent of like
etsy games uh that we can sell to you
kind of because they appeal appeal to
the audience but we we see
our audience is aging up like the the
people who buy my games in particular
are the older audience who who have no
problem with paying twenty dollars
because they're getting something that
they feel is authored
there's no micro transactions there's
that kind of game that they like
but the younger audience coming up
couldn't care less about
the uh well it was someone playing my
games but like couldn't but as a whole
they're they're into fortnite they're
playing games they're free games are
free
i might buy a cool outfit but games are
free they don't yeah that's all it takes
different shift i feel like but with
fortnite as the example all it takes is
one game
to shake that whole thing up again to
come along and be like like if
you know let's say that we enter into
this period where it's
only games dominating the landscape like
fortnight games of service type games
for years and years and then
and then you know five years into that
there's a there's a relaunch of the
uncharted series there's
a new god of war for the first time in
in a decade or there's a new and then
suddenly it's like oh [ __ ] this is the
craze and the whole thing shifts again
but that takes a lot of right that
you've got to be pretty brave to be
those
the people who invest the money into
that kind of project so i guess it'll be
four guys
i wrote a really big picture about this
exact thing about like games of service
and why things are trending that way i
think i interviewed like 26
different studios um and one of the
things
uh that multiple people said that i
wouldn't have realized if i hadn't
done that outreach was that uh trends
are showing that
gamers are playing more of video games
but buying less diversity of video games
so
gamers right now are i believe playing
more hours
and putting more money into the same one
thing and buying less things overall
so if you want fortnite minecraft pretty
much i still play minecraft
if you want people to put to to invest
in your
company you ultimately have to make a
games a service game
uh get them on that versus everything
else rather than releasing three games
in a year because they aren't going to
buy three they're going to buy one and
play it for
400 hours but that's why i feel like in
the same way that the beatles needed the
stones
fortnite needed pub g
right because pub g tested those waters
proved it and fortnight went hold my
beer which is why it's so interesting
because it was like dayz and h1z1 like
that that trend took such a long time to
to get to fortnite for sure and they
still had saved the world to start with
it i was gonna say fortnite did not
begin
as as a battle royale oh dude i remember
fred tatushore and i went in and did a
trailer for fortnite
and and then years later i mean we're
talking like
years later donald mustard even reminded
me that like you remember that trailer
we did i'm like
yeah when does that game come out he
goes like ah no
no we're doing something different now
but it was a totally different game
yeah and i think that i'm getting emails
like crazy no no no i i just
it it to me is and i i've even said this
to donald like
i appreciate what fortnite has been able
to accomplish
but i don't think it's necessarily good
for games i think that it's
it becomes in the same sense it's a
black hole it just it draws in people to
gaming
but it doesn't allow them to view the
landscape it's so you're so hyper
focused on just one thing
um and i think they agree with that
yeah i think fortnite does a lot of
really cool stuff uh i agree
a platform i think it's incredibly cool
that's the thing it's it's almost like
second life at this point like it's it's
a licensing platform
it's yeah i mean they put a blackberry
statue in this week which i thought was
really nice
yeah it's the closest thing to the oasis
from ready player that we have right so
i mean i i think that there's really
cool things that they do
not only has it shifted like more people
are playing but it's also
it's it's shifting towards event gaming
as opposed to like the whole seasons
thing was was kind of a big motion
to do what's surprising plus not to
mention that they're
i think you know and obviously i'm
speaking
um on mike's turf with this one but
their ability to
their ability to um inject
capital into the into game developers um
obviously as a play to make the epic
store a thing but just to me if
if nothing else so many developers
have received money from epic on the
back of fortnite to make their game that
has nothing to do with fortnite that
that alone i'm like
i have a hard time looking anything
negative about even if i hated the game
which i don't at all
but let's just say i thought it
represented the the death of games and
all things evil
it would be hard to make that claim on
the sheer base that is exactly what
choice is
remember what i'm saying it's the death
of games and all evil
give me an example because i i may not
be aware of this i'm so babe in the
woods in this episode but what what are
you talking about
like what the sheer the [ __ ] well yeah
like
maybe a certain uh go ahead yeah i mean
i don't think it's it's not in no way
private that john wick hex was was
released exclusively on the epic store
at launch oh no no no okay i didn't do
that that wasn't free
i thought you were saying though
fortnite specifically i didn't i mean
obviously epic as the umbrella would
have been the fortnight money
like he's i think austin's 100 right
like i don't think i would have
i don't think well i mean i don't think
the epic store would be doing those kind
of deals if they didn't have just this
enormous
bag you could make that case
not all companies are doing that right
so like ea i feel like are in this like
complicated position where they have
ultimate team
which makes so much money that when you
look at you know their
shareholder meetings because ea's
publicly traded company you got to be
like but why aren't all these games
making that much money why is that one
making that much money and how do we
make all the others make that much money
you're failing if you're not making
ultimate team money which is absurd
because nothing else is making ultimate
d money i don't think fortnite's even
making ultimate team money it's absurd
really i don't think so i think it's
still ultimate team makes more money i
think
gta is definitely up there with shot
cards
uh but i don't i spend so much money on
shark cards i know so that's how they
get yeah and that's gonna be a problem
with them too
it's is that they're gonna be like how
do we make shot card money and
everything and that that becomes this
like massive trend but
in theory you could say that ea
puts that money into the ea originals
program because i mean
that you know ultimate team was making a
lot of money and they still shut down
visceral
it's still it's still they've still had
losses as a result of like you know
making a tremendous amount of money i
feel like for them it's becoming
everyone else needs to make more not a
we can put this funding into
dead space 4 which is just a whole mess
but
and i probably spoke about it on the
show before but i always try to hype it
up because i think it's fantastic and
and you know a lot of people hate ea but
you've got to give them credit for when
they do something right too the ea
originals program
ea doesn't profit from that program at
all the indie studios keep their ip
and they make all of the money yeah so
like a way out
for example ea paid for the marketing
and
i think they get they get their money
back
but that made joseph ferris rich because
isn't a way out the uh [ __ ] the oscars
guy
yes that's what say all of their
marketing dollars they went we just need
to let him loose
yeah exactly did any of you play that
game
i i i've had that game installed uh
in my ea store uh and i've but i've
never actually played it but it looked
it looked decent it's pretty fun co-op
game yeah played it through my
girlfriend yeah
it's pretty fun that's the thing is i
feel like i would want to play it with
someone else
yeah you do you do uh the other one was
like faye
or feyer um which is zoink games who i
think make a lot of really
nice indie games they have a really
really creative catalog of stuff that
they make that i really appreciate but
that it's the same thing they keep the
ip
and they get all of the profit it's like
yay i don't understand why they're doing
it because they're not doing it for
positive pr because they don't talk
about it
i'm like what i don't i just don't get
it interesting but in theory
they're the kiana they're the keanu of
uh big publishers
just sort of quietly do human kindness
that
no one's paying attention to potentially
a
um recruitment thing
get to get working with those studios i
i really don't know but you you could
make the case that like ultimate team
money gives them the blanket where they
can do that and they are helping indie
studios really significantly for the
ones that actually do partner with the
originals program it's super impressive
for the record it wasn't always like
that i did have friends who were in
talks with ea about the originals
program at a point in time where it was
much more restrictive but i guess they
opened it up so
um yeah it's it's cool and it's it's
just it's just
the games of service thing makes things
really complicated because like i said
everyone
every publicly traded company in the
industry is looking at every other
publicly traded company in the industry
and saying
why aren't we making this much money how
do we make that much money
and that's why i think like i'm very
glad that playstation operates
the way that they do because i don't
think they're going ahead in that
direction
when they want to continue having their
studios make these
big blockbuster aaa titles with a lot of
creative freedom because then
people will buy a playstation 5. people
will feel passionately about the the
caliber of the quality of games which is
even then an interesting one
because statistically people buy more
third-party games
than first-party games anyway but glad
that they still exist and i hope that
other people keep that up but there's
all
right go ahead there's always there's
always a money funnel like that's the
thing is like and it's not i don't think
it's a cynical statement obviously as
you said any publicly traded company the
primary objective is to make money and
most privately funded companies like the
objective is to make consistent income
so you can pay your staff right so
there's always a money funnel so it's
it's come up with you know with
remasters often even if they're not
selling it to
sell to make money off the units they
sell it's a marketing thing with the
console guys they're trying to sell the
console there's always
there's always an angle ea has to do uh
you know live service games because they
don't have a thing they can sell you for
five hundred dollars
to put on your tv so they have to be
working out different routes to
to making that money so it's it's kind
of always just very kind of logical and
predictable usually that you can kind of
go
okay well someone that the reason
they're doing this is definitely money
because of course it is there's usually
a pretty straightforward route to where
that would come in
i always one of them
it is but it's also realistic like i
always want to say in a lot of these
cases especially where ea is concerned
people be like why is their press
conference bad
like i'm not interested in any of this
are they stupid i'm like no it's that
you're not their main customer the stock
market is
like sure you buy the games but ea
doesn't care if gamers don't like their
press conferences that's
it just is doesn't matter okay be mad
i'm sure there are people in pr and
marketing teams who do take that stuff
seriously and try very hard i don't want
to discredit any of them
um i've had friends who worked in ea
marketing and it sounded like it was
tremendously difficult but
you know that's it's it's ultimately
when it comes down to it shareholders
stock market other actual customers
um the um the notion of a remaster as
marketing just kind of
slightly reeling it back to earlier the
one that i keep turning around in my
head wondering about be
because i think that's a very fair
observation that
you know the sequel is always announced
six months after a successful
remaster release or whatever case in
point one of the
um ones a couple years ago was when
um double fine did a pretty thorough
remaster on grim fandango
and my only thought would be i heard
that that actually did very well for
double fine because
it introduced it to a whole that that
game it had been 20 years basically
since that game
came out and and obviously it had never
been available on modern
hardware um and so um
uh that you know exposed it to a whole
new crowd
and so it was almost like a new release
but they did put considerable resources
into that and i guess it's just sort of
the brand elevation of
double fine itself as opposed to like
and now grim fandango too
well actually with double fine that
might be the exception that proves the
rule like
double finds really interesting i can't
remember what his i'm really embarrassed
i can't remember the name of
i think former now cfr oh it's tim
schmidt
the cfo the guy who stood next to tim
schaefer with a big bag of money that
guy
um who was very good one of the things i
remember
uh kind of hearing through the grapevine
one of the brilliant things double fine
did and i think they even they covered
this in the documentary they made um
double fine are so good at finding um
old revenue streams and working out how
to because they just constantly
throughout their entire existence needed
cash to keep making games
so they were very good actually going
okay well we've got grim fandango
we could probably make some money from
that so keep so get the remaster done so
at that scale because they were in that
kind of middle space between aaa and
indy they were kind of in that middle
zone
with their san francisco office and
their large staff like they needed to be
making
serious money but not triple a money um
right now because they've been um they
are game pass model now they're owned by
xbox so watching them is going to be
super interesting how much does double
fine
transition yeah well i can tell you that
with
the the case of great fandango as
someone who regularly
refers to that as possibly my all-time
favorite game
one of the funny things about it this is
i know this this this is a town you've
got to be quick busting because troy has
to go
yeah troy's very politely told us all to
hurry up and move along
hey everybody everybody shut the [ __ ] up
i gotta go
well then that was a perfect moment for
a tangent so
one of the things that stood out about
grim fandango was 1998 it was one of the
first games that
had pervasively live
musicians in the score uh and it was not
all uh done with midi and it was the
reason why is because it was a lot of
solo instruments it was
it was a low-cost score to produce by
comparison uh but the thing that always
bugged me
as a player was that as someone who
listened to a lot of
orchestral music growing up um i'd be
playing the game and you'd have this
you know amazing you know growling tenor
sax solo when you're in like hector le
mans office and then you have
manny calavero with his you know
beautiful tango played by peter
mcconnell
and then there'd be like a scene of you
moving along the edge of the rooftop to
sneak into the office
and this fake orchestra comes in that's
just so obviously fake and so the thing
that i loved was part of the remaster
was they hired the melbourne symphony
and they they picked up those
those oh no way there's very very few
cues in the score that use an orchestra
but for those few that do
they swapped them out and actually
recorded them properly so the 95 percent
of the score was basically done
and perfect for 20 years and then they
finally kind of did a 20-year
patch on the uh the fake bits and i was
just for austin wintry he's like yeah
i noticed i actually i actually begged
them to conduct those sessions because i
was like i
i i don't have to pay me i just have to
and they were like the problem is it's
in two days and it's in melbourne and
it's like a three hour it's a very short
set
it's been ten times more time on the
plane
getting here
you know that's like that's a proper
remaster yeah
all right well i've read about the topic
of remembering planes we gotta go
bye everyone bye